hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute einen
leckeren mandl blechkuchen und das tolle
ist wir brauchen nicht viel zeit was
aber nicht bedeutet dass der kuchen
nicht lecker schmeckt weil er so
blitzschnell geben gegenteil der
schmeckt richtig richtig gut und zwar
bereiten jetzt erst den teig zu und
später machen wir die leckere mangel
kruste für den teig benötigen wir mehr
naturjoghurt die habe ich den fed
angenommen außerdem zucker eine bio
zitrone backpulver und etwas vanille
zucker so für den teig nämlich jetzt
keine maschine sondern macht das ganz
einfach mit dem schneebesen und wir
machen das so dass wählt er ist ein kurt
und den zitronenscheiben abriss sowie
die zucker sorten in eine schüssel geben
und dann gut miteinander verrühren
[Musik]
ich hab das ganze jetzt eine gute minute
miteinander verrührt und als nächstes
die trockenen zutaten hinein also mehl
und backpulver und geben das aber
unbedingt durch einen sieg
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann alle zutaten miteinander
gut verrührt hat merkte dass der teig
ein bisschen fester und klebriger wird
und genau so ist es richtig und den ofen
habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt jetzt
nehme ich mir meinen backblech da habe
ich einfach drum herum gelegt ich werde
euch die maß aber auf jeden fall um den
die infobox schreiben sorgt er einfach
den vorteil dass alles richtig schön
akkurat gerade ist und jetzt würde ich
den teig ein und dann wird er gebacken
[Musik]
und den teig streich der oberfläche noch
schön glaube das geht entweder mit
seiner teil karte oder er macht sich
einfach die hände nass das klappt auch
wunderbar und dann geht der teig
vorgebacken 180 grad ober und unterhitze
für 20 minuten der teig durfte jetzt vor
backen der ist jetzt goldbraun der sitz
zugegebenermaßen gerade ein bisschen
lustig aus aber wir machen jetzt unsere
leckere mangel kruste obendrauf dafür
nehmen wir flüssige butter geben das zu
den gehobelte mandeln und soca mediation
das karamellisiert dann richtig schön
[Musik]
sodann verteilt ihr die mandel machst du
schön auf dem kuchen und jetzt kommt es
zurück in den ofen der ist ja noch auf
180 grad er bleibt er auch und dann so
für ungefähr fünf bis sieben minuten bis
das richtig schön karamellisiert sondern
wenn der kuchen dann aus dem ofen kommt
der kennt ihn nicht wieder denn die
kruste dieser mangel kruste ist richtig
schön karamellisiert und goldbraun und
dann könnt ihr das genießen wenn sich
besucher morgens ankündigen und sagt ob
ich kommen mittags vorbei jetzt aber mal
schönes spiel
die schwiegermama kommt dann könnten wir
natürlich auch zubereiten und gerne
genießen zu einem kaffee und ich hab
euch natürlich die genauen mengenangaben
hier unten in die infobox schreibt mir
gerne euer feedback wenn ihr den kuchen
mal ausprobiert habt da geht ja wirklich
super schnell das liebe ich total
und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr dem
video eines deutlichen nach oben da ist
mein kanal kostenlos abonniert dann
sehen wir uns nämlich auch beim nächsten
mal wieder auf die keys kitchen tschüss
und am internet abo nierenwärmer private
einblicke sehen möchtet schnell rüber
auf instagram es falsch ist
[Musik]